well kim's convenience is the story of a
korean-canadian family
uh the parents are immigrants they came
over here and basically set up shop
um they've been doing it for a very long
time and the story is about them as well
as their kids
myself and andrea who plays janet and
how we deal with their crazy antics
and there's a lot of laughs but there's
also a lot of heart
it's based on a really great play
written by ins troy called kim's
convenience as well
and if you've seen the play you kind of
know what kind of
humor slash emotion that we're going for
and for both of you uh had you seen the
play is it
a play you were aware of or only after
kind of signing on to this project
um for me i actually didn't hear about
it until
once i signed on um but once i did i
immediately read it and actually my
sister had seen it when it came to
vancouver
and my mom who's heavily in the korean
society back in vancouver
her friends seen it but yeah i read the
play after and it like
i laughed and i cried when i read it
it's it's so good and i can't wait to
watch it
live like when it goes to new york
or when it comes back here um i actually
watched it
december of last year for the first time
and i'd heard about it but
you know it there were runs i think um i
just didn't quite catch them and so last
year was when i was able to get tickets
and uh
and yeah i was just emotionally wrecked
you know it's not every day that people
who look like
who look like me can actually go to a
play and see
you know the actors on stage playing
what what is basically my lived
experience because
i immigrated from china when i was very
very young and you know my parents same
thing they
came over here with nothing and they
wanted to start you know they wanted to
build a better life for their kids
and so you know the majority of theater
is not
does not tell that specific story and so
it was really refreshing
and also really refreshing to you know
to see my you know the
father-son dynamic being played out on
screen and it just it was it was great
and you mentioned it's a big deal for to
see that in a play yeah but now to see
that on a national show
yeah is a breakthrough how do you feel
about being part of
that diversity in tv and film right now
such a hot topic
what's it like to be a part of a show
that's kind of pushing that boundary
i'm super excited particularly
because when i was growing up there was
nothing for me
to relate to so i think it's
really amazing to not only have the show
but be a part of it
and hopefully have people relate to i
hope characters that i wish i could
relate to when i was younger
it's also terrifying because you feel
like
i mean at least for me in the first i
think for both of us we were just
talking about this yesterday
at lunch but like the first couple of
weeks of shooting we kind of came to
work every day with this kind of anxiety
and this sense of
burden and pressure and because you know
we felt like we were representing so
much more than just ourselves and um
you know i found that that actually it
somewhat hinders your work because
you're so nervous all the time
you don't want to you know let down an
entire
you know a community of people
so the good thing is i think as shooting
went on we eventually learned to be a
little more comfortable and just to
have fun with the process but no it's
like we know how big of a responsibility
it is
and and yeah it's hard at first
it must feel like an honor to be able to
bring yeah
i i think you you did a tweet said that
our small show that's going to change
the world so
is this what you're referring to or is
there something else no this is
absolutely the show that i was referring
to
yeah yeah i mean i can't wait to see
what what people think of it because i
mean there's
there's a couple of uh asian family
sitcoms you know popping up in the
states and those are great but i
i think that kim's has is a very
different tone than than kind of that
abc
um not to talk down in any way because i
i love the show and i think it's really
funny but there's this kind of like
disney brand
of sitcom that's a little wacky and a
little goofy and really funny
but i think kim's what what we are is is
really just
real and and we really get into the
family dynamic and
and i think a lot of people like us who
grew up you know who's pa
we have parents who speak a different
language and home um they're really able
to understand some of our struggles and
and
the experiences that we go through and
if you can talk a little bit about the
dynamic of the family on the show
because
i understand you're estranged from the
family
you you don't want to work in the family
business yeah um what what's it like
um what's the family dynamic like on the
show and then offset with the four of
you
um i'll okay i'll talk i'll talk about
the onset stuff you talk about the
offset stuff
okay tandem okay sibling let's do it
um well in the story yeah
chung is is somebody who you know was a
bad apple in the family and when he was
when he was in high school he actually
dropped out um
you know started running with the wrong
crowds gone into juvie
for a while and at the beginning of the
show he's kind of trying to pick his
life back up
and so he's kind of re-established
contact with most of the family except
for
his dad or appa and there's kind of an
animosity between the two
that becomes kind of a central theme
over the course of the season and
and i can't say whether or not it gets
resolved or anything but um
you know that's definitely it's a big
part of of the family dynamic and it's
kind of a hole
in the middle so the family in my mind
is is
not complete at the start of our story
and then for uh for you um are you guys
like a family
like the cast have you guys become that
family unit
yeah yeah definitely we
i think from especially because knowing
what the show means too i think
immediately we're like
we'll band together as a family so we
know we hung out
when it's before it even started to get
to know each other and
everyone's super duper nice
um like yeah
yeah like we went out for korean food
yesterday
yeah we do it all the time and um
and it's really funny because you know
obviously uh paul and jean who play our
parents
you know english is actually their first
language so
it's funny how how countered to there
because they're basically playing
versions of their parents
and it's funny how in real life they're
so different i mean paul gives off a
wonderful
guiding presence for everyone totally
true but like
he is so funny and he curses like a
sailor
and and gene two actually they're
they're both pretty foul balanced
so who who on set is kind of cracking up
and ruining the most takes
paul it's definitely paul i mean i i
don't have too many scenes with him but
i feel like he's the one that always
gets going but it's hard because even
when you do a scene with paul like i've
cracked so many times
even when it's like someone else's
coverage really really bad
um but because he's just so funny he's
hilarious
yeah but he cracks a lot too yeah i love
that in one of the teasers i saw
um it's a senior in and you guys are
talking about how there are no
cool christian korean guys
it seems like this show's gonna have a
lot of like those really funny like
one-liners that we're gonna hear a lot
is that is that true will people is this
a laugh out loud type of show
i think so like we screened the first
few
first two episodes for the cast and crew
um and everyone there's a lot of laughs
there's also
it's not only a show that has a lot of
laughs but there's also a lot of like
heartwarming moments as well
yeah it's it's the kind of like you you
laugh and then you don't see it coming
and then we give you a gut punch of
emotion
yeah and actually about paul i just have
to talk about this because paul cracking
he cracks both ways like we you know the
one of the few scenes that i shot with
paul
he he was like he was he just lost it
emotionally
and it was because i know like he comes
from a very emotionally open place he's
so
it's so amazing seeing him work and and
you know anytime we have a father and
son stuff and it gets me
but it gets him too because he's not
only does he have his own issues with
his father but he's got two boys
and he's thinking about all these things
and i just see him on screen i see the
tears welling up and then i go
and uh it's it's tough to get through
those types of scenes too
and are your parents i guess extremely
proud that you're working on a project
like this has it kind of brought up any
emotion with you guys yeah i mean i can
speak to myself like when i decided to
be an actor four years ago
um you know my parents weren't always
super duper supportive and they were
very unsure because
it was you know it's it's not a very
stable industry to be in and
you know it's a lot of uncertainty and
um
you know hopefully with the show they'll
watch it and they'll they'll be happy
that you know i'm working
and having fun um i'm my background is
my parents are korean and but i was born
here so very much
like the story so my mom is super
excited
her and her friends she i'm sure she's
like bragging about it with her friends
i just talked to her recently and she's
like oh when you go out you better look
beautiful
she's really excited and it's like i'm
excited for her to get to watch a show
that
is hopefully like reminiscent of aspects
of her life